[Musique]
écoutez monsieur head un ancien
conducteur il a parcouru un nombre de
kilomètres égal à 20 fois le tour de la
terre
alors j'ai même commencé par le de
motorage sur bandage et alors c'est que
quelques années après qu'on a mis des
pneumatique à la suite d'une campagne de
presse
l'oeuvre parce que l'oeuvre avait publié
une photographie que les cochons étaient
mieux transportés que les Parisiens vous
avez connu les embouteillages qu'on
connaît maintenant en ce moment alors à
ce moment là qu'il y avait pas de sens
unique il y avait autant de
embouteillages qui en a maintenant
dégoûté avant 1914 et je peux vous dire
qu'il y avait jamais de problème de
circulation pour circuler à Paris alors
à la guerre 14 beaucoup de voitures par
connait quand beaucoup d'autobus sont
partis faire les transports propres
après la guerre 14 et bien on est revenu
donc au système de circulation de 1914
mais en augmentant le parc d'autobus et
alors à partir
de 1921
il y a eu le problème fatalement de
l'embouteillage qui se produisait à
cause qu'il y avait pas de sens unique
alors quand ils ont institué le sens
unique ça l'est beaucoup mieux en 1929
on a créé un nouveau modèle d'autobus
Renault type PN il était petit il y
avait que 36 places en tant que me
souvienne et il se conduisait comme un
taxi alors 1939 les voitures ont été
mobilisées pour amener les troupes sur
le pont et puis alors 40 alors il y a eu
des transports de troupes au mois de mai
alors qu'elle était comme conséquence
l'autobus à gaz à cause qu'il n'y avait
pas n'est-ce pas d'essence alors on a
mis un immense ballon sur les toits
d'autobus qu'il fallait rentrer au dépôt
deux fois et même trois fois chaque jour
pour le remplissage pour alimenter le
moteur maintenant avec le nouveau type
de matériel de matériel il n'y a aucune
comparaison avec cela alors là déjà au
point de vue chauffage maniabilité
tout ce qui est automatique
le volant assisté le cerveau frein et
surtout
embrayage automatique qui permet
maintenant aux femmes de conduire ces
grosses autobus modernes aussi
facilement que les femmes qui qui
conduisent un taxi
[Musique]